well hey y'all good morning I am so
excited to be here I'm surrounded oh my
goodness this is just what a privilege
and honor to be with you to help kick
off in DC Oslo 2019 this is one of my
nearest and dearest to my heart
conferences my first international
speaking opportunity was here at in DC
Oslo years ago and I it's just such an
honor and privilege to be with you and
I'm gonna feel really awkward standing
or looking around at everyone but I want
to make sure that I get to see everybody
you have bears here are there bears in
Norway sure a few maybe I don't know I
used to work for this really awesome
company where we talked about punching
bears it was all about doing hard things
and being scrappy and resourceful and
going against you know bigger companies
and bigger competition and you know
taking on on hard stuff about getting
out there and we would say things like
get out there and put some bears today
well in in real life punching a bear
might not be such a great idea
as it will only provoke the bear to maul
you worse than before this has nothing
to do with my keynote I just thought you
would like some free advice now some of
you are excited to be here you can't
wait to get to all these different
sessions and and learn about all this
new technology and have great
conversations I hope you do more than
just go to a sessions that you meet
people and that you get to hear about
what what other people are doing and how
they're solving problems were at their
workplace and hope you make some new
friends this is a great opportunity to
meet folks from all over the world some
of you on the other hand may be feeling
a little bit you know anxious
and overwhelm there's gonna be you know
throughout the day and the next few days
are gonna be getting all this new
information and having a you're thinking
to yourself well how am I going to learn
all this new stuff and how am I going to
convince my boss to let me do any of
this right and you know we could talk
about how the future of computing is
serverless whatever the heck that means
we could talk about IOT and machine
learning or artificial intelligence
those are all you know hot topics and
how we should be connecting all the
devices in our home to the Internet and
reaping all the benefits or we could
talk about the latest JavaScript
framework that came out only five
minutes ago
you should stop everything that you're
doing and use this brand new thing right
well my goal here this morning is to
encourage you to see your your life
through a bigger lens to maybe I want
you to walk away with a bigger and maybe
a clearer perspective on what you're
capable of doing and what you're capable
of achieving in your life I'm here to
tell you that you are awesome you may
not believe that yet you may not yet
realize it but you have some pretty
amazing tools that you were born with
unfortunately we have to deal with lies
as we get older there are more and more
lives that kind of sneaked into our
heads right there lies that people have
told us lies that we've told ourselves
the lives that the world tries to
convince us of we we fall into a trap of
comparing ourselves to others and and
think well I don't measure up to this
other person
or this other person's successes well
that's that's hogwash that's that's not
right so I I want you to stop listening
to those lies I want and I want to give
you some truth and the truth is you are
smart
you are strong you are beautiful you can
sing
maybe metaphorically speaking you know
maybe you can sing through the things
that you create through the software
that you create the projects or the
artistic expressions or all kinds of
things you are loved you are loved right
now you deserve to be loved
and you will be loved in the future you
are not a failure mistakes in life are
inevitable everyone makes mistakes
that's how you learn things I make
mistakes all the time behind every
successful person is a burning trash
heap of mistakes but mistakes don't make
you a failure you are not broken the
things that that are different about you
those are what make you extraordinary
you are wonderful you matter to someone
you are valuable more valuable than all
the wealth in the world you as a person
are valuable you are never too far gone
don't give up on yourself you belong you
are amazing
you are awesome so don't believe those
lies you are not defined by them and you
have no need to compare yourself to
others you are the most awesome person
you've ever met you are born with an
insatiable desire to learn new things
and it's you have capacity to do all
kinds of things more than you can
imagine and you're never too young or
too old to learn something new
creativity and imagination though those
are like a muscle that you can the more
you use it the stronger it becomes now
as you've gotten older you may you know
when you were born and when you were
young you were full of imagination and
creativity you know wild dreams and
imagination I and I tell you that you
just need to start exercising those
things again about four years ago I
discovered that I liked to draw and I
had a had a passion I discovered this
passion for drawing okay it's more like
this but I started out drawing crude
stick figures and lines and arrows and
shapes and these were just to help the
presentations that I was giving just to
add some some character and some humor
to the talks that I gave and when I
started out I you know I was not very
good at drawing I about three years ago
I drew this for one of my talks and I
was I spent a lot of time on it a lot of
attention and I was so proud of it and
you know you may recognize this maybe as
one of those memes right and when I
would show this before I would give a
demo for my talks people would would
chuckle and and laugh and I about a year
ago I decided well I want to try drawing
that same thing again and I
is flabbergasted I was like oh man I
can't believe how much better I've
gotten and how far I've come and I'm not
I'm not telling you this story to brag
I'm telling you this because I am amazed
it just you know with the practice in
the and the things that I've done that
I've been able to improve and got and
I've gotten better at at doing this and
people will tell me wow you're so gifted
and I say no I that's not it the gift is
that spark of imagination it's that
spark of you know what is it that you're
passionate about the gift is every day
that you're given the time that you
spend to do the things that you are
excited about I am convinced that
anything that you want to learn anything
that you want to do you can do it it
just takes some determination
some practice and a lot of patience
there's gonna be times when you don't
think you're making any progress but if
you keep doing the thing that you like
over time you can look back and say oh
wow I can't believe how far I've come
and this applies to you know it was kind
of like one of those aha well well duh
moments for me when I looked at my how
far I've gotten as an artist I was like
well it's the same thing about
programming learning a new language
learning a new framework you're gonna
really stink at it when you first start
but it takes time practice and patience
to get better and you can apply the same
principle if you want to learn and eat
the new language or to learn a musical
instrument or to learn to be an artist
anything that you are
say in your mind you think well man I
wish I could do that well maybe you just
need to take take some time and and make
a habit of practice we love stories
about heroes there's something that just
resonates within us when we hear about
these you know the movies and the books
and this and the you know all these
different ways that we we consume these
stories about heroes it's usually
someone who's who's ordinary or they
don't yet know what they're capable of
and that something usually in the story
that where someone or something comes
along and calls out in them their true
potential and their ability take neo in
the matrix for example he doesn't know
what he's capable of and it's usually
something that that comes about that it
causes them to begin to realize what
they're capable of and start to believe
in themselves
I just recently watched Captain Marvel
man I thought that was an awesome
awesome story and I loved I don't want
to give anything away but throughout the
most of the movie she doesn't know how
much power she actually has and at the
end when the guy is trying to tell her
to get her to believe some of those old
lies and try to manipulate her again she
says I have nothing to prove to you so
powerful well I want you to know that
you are the hero in your story
you are capable of more than you realize
you can do bigger things then you have
yet imagined you can do
you are awesome
and I want you to encourage you to
maximize your strengths and to find
those things that you're passionate
about and and be awesome at those things
but there's more to your story than just
being really good at some things you
have a purpose it's not enough just to
be awesome you are created to share your
awesomeness with other people I believe
that our purpose in life can be summed
up in one thing it's leave it better
than you found it and it's not just
about leaving the planet better than we
found it but it's about leaving every
encounter every relationship that you
have you have your workplace your family
your community your friends random
people that you meet every day each
encounter is an opportunity where you
can make a positive impact on others and
to leave it better than you found it
people are watching you they notice how
you react to situations how you treat
other people how they they watch your
character and they see when you take
responsibility when you keep your word
when you forgive others did you know
that different people have different
personalities right different people
behave differently to situations with
they have different ways of seeing the
world and they have different ways that
they like to receive information how
they process information and how they
respond to conflict and our industry
attracts a lot of people Willis a
optimal people skills we can get quite
far in our careers on just our technical
skills alone but you know and most of us
are more comfortable talking to our
computers than we are to the people that
are around us but like it or not we are
relational beings we are designed to
live in community
I admit to you that there are three
inevitable things in life there's death
taxes and PowerPoint sooner or later
it's going to happen you're gonna be
expected to get up in front of some
people and give some kind of
presentation you know if you're whether
it's your workplace or you know maybe a
wedding or you know just some scenario
and in 2011 I finally got up the courage
to give my first talk and I stank I was
terrible but a funny thing happened I
had people come up to me and thanked me
for the talk that I gave even though you
know it was it was awful and I had
people who told me I did a great job
even though I was certain I was the
worst speaker in speaker history it took
a while for it to to sink in but I
learned a valuable lesson about the
power of community there are people out
there that who are really awesome at
being human who will look past your
mistakes who will see the good and
potential that are in you and will
inspire you or encourage you to not give
up because when you do hard things like
share your knowledge and experience with
everyone benefits I hope every day I'm
more like one of those kinds of people I
want to encourage you to do hard stuff
so that we all benefit here's one of my
favorite quotes when I gave my first
talk people didn't remember that I
fumbled around with some demo failure
they don't remember all the us and arms
and mistakes that I made but they
remembered me and they remembered that
maybe even in some small way I helped
them with their their life or their
career or the technology that they're
trying to learn in 2016 I had the
privilege of giving a keynote at music
city code in Nashville Tennessee which
is where I used to live and I had more
than one person come up to me after that
talk and say hey I was there I remember
when you gave your first talk and you're
right you were terrible well thank you
thank you and you might be thinking to
yourself well I can understand being
forced to speak or you know why would I
volunteer to give a talk to a group of
people so let me tell you having someone
not only understand your message but
then be inspired to go and actually do
that thing that you're talking about
that is one of the most rare and
precious rewards I have ever experienced
and public speaking is an amazing skill
that you can learn that can set you
apart from from other people and can
open up all kinds of doors of
opportunities and there's there's lots
and lots of other benefits to being a
speaker but there are so many other ways
that you can share your knowledge and
experience
speaking is just one of countless ways
that you can contribute to the community
in the and to share your awesomeness
with others now there's a real struggle
there's this real thing called a
impostor syndrome and that's what keeps
a lot of people from sharing their
experiences it's this idea that you feel
like you're not worthy or that your
ideas and your knowledge
don't you know aren't worthy enough to
present or that someone's going to call
you out and call you a fraud well I've
talked to a lot of people over the years
this is a universal feeling everyone
feels this way well except for a few
freaks you know we know who those people
are but one thing that I want to
encourage you is that not only do a lot
of people experience this and it's okay
and you can move beyond that you can is
still okay to share your experiences is
that you don't have to be an expert to
to share your knowledge and experience
with others you you have something that
no one else has and that is your
experience people can argue semantics
they can argue best practices or
whatever all day long but they cannot
argue with your experience don't be
afraid to share your knowledge and
experience with others have you ever
heard of the Dilbert principle it's
basically those the most ineffective
workers are systematically promoted to
the position where they can do the least
amount of harm and that's management
early in my career I worked for under a
manager who exemplified this Dilbert
principle I really did not like the man
personally or professionally and I his
is he was notoriously bad he you know
mistakes were named after him and yet he
still continued to rise in rank and
responsibilities a lot of the work I had
to do under his direction was of no
value to anyone in case in point I I was
asked to create this huge binder of
documentation for every method in my
code every store procedure no one was
gonna read this ever pointless work is
soul-crushing I did everything that I
could to get out from under his
direction but after more than a year I
quit and found another job and I said to
myself life is too short to work
somewhere that stinks and I started
living by this philosophy I started
offering it as advice to other people
when they started to complain about
their workplace in technology we have an
incredible privilege where we're in such
high demand that we can pick and choose
where we get to work we can leave one
job for another and not everyone has
that kind of opportunity the problem is
that idea began to pollute my
perspective and when I was in some new
job and things started to go sour I
would think oh great here we go again
I've seen this before time to look for a
new job and I was in a similar situation
and I was unhappy with the work that I
was doing or the work the way things
were going at work and I had a very
attractive job offer on the table and I
was trying to decide if I should take
this job offer
and that's when my wife asked me two
questions that stopped me in my tracks
have you done everything that you can do
and if you left now would you have any
regrets fine I declined the job offer
and I took ownership of the situation
and I did everything I possibly could to
make that situation better and to make
my team successful in the end I still
left that job
one year later but I left having no
regrets and I left being extremely proud
of the work that we had accomplished it
had been one of the most prolific years
in my career now sure there can be
career limiting situations there can be
you know toxic environments that you you
know you're you don't have to stay in
and there can be really amazing
opportunities that come along that
justify leaving a job but for everything
else I have a new mindset life is too
short to let things stay the way they
are I've learned that taking ownership
and responsibility is always the right
thing to do you've probably heard it
said well that's not my job you know
that's not in my job description
might not be your job but people will
notice if you do something like take
responsibility for a situation to make
it better or for you to go to your
leadership and say what can I do to help
make this better what can I do to make a
better impact on our team and our work
every now and again we have to say
goodbye to people that we work with
sometimes you know really really awesome
people really good people that we're
going to miss and regardless of the
circumstances we let them know how much
we're going to miss them and sometimes
we throw a party a going-away party
that's and we tell stories about you
know some of the cool things that they
did or funny things that they will be
remembered for and it occurred to me
when a few years ago when some I had
some really good awesome people that I
worked with that we're leaving and we're
and we're having the celebration of all
the contributions and things that they
had given to our company and I I was
thinking what wow this is really awesome
this is really special why don't we do
this more often
why do we have to wait until someone's
leaving the company before we'll tell
them hey if you did such an incredible
job so I decided to run an experiment
every Friday for I would I would come up
with a description for someone I would
post this on our slack channel I would
this is just one example Makoto was our
Customer Support Manager and as someone
described he did the work of 10,000
people he consistently went above and
beyond what he was expected to do to
make our customers happy and he is
really awesome
now the drawing isn't important it's
just something fun that I like to do and
usually what I said about that person
wasn't all that earth-shattering either
it wasn't all that amazing the real
magic the real magic was what everyone
else said
throughout the day person after person
providing you know stories and examples
of the incredible awesome things that
that person had done either either at
work or outside of work you know some of
the passions and and cool things that
they did it was really really beautiful
all I did was start the conversation I
had so many people who would come up to
me and thanked me for being recognized
or for recognizing someone that they
cared about that they worked with every
one of us wants to know that the things
we do matter that the work that we do
has value in significance that we have
value and significance and when you
encourage someone you highlight that
person's strengths and you it's it's
positive reinforcement that person now
wants to go and do those same things
that got them recognition reflecting
back over more than ten years of agile
development I've come to the conclusion
that respect for people really is the
more fundamental principle having
respect and showing respect is the fuel
that enables teams to be successful for
companies to be successful for products
to be successful
it is what enables all those other
facets of good programming and
team-building it's it starts with
respect something you should know about
me is I can't go for very long without
talking about bacon so I submit to you
my highest award for excellence the
bacon award and when you can encourage
someone or a group or a team they will
continue to improve and create amazing
results and the cool thing is they can
go on to inspire others to do amazing
and cool things and it becomes this this
awesome virtuous cycle and you can be
the person that starts that conversation
that starts that kind of movement in
your community in your workplace now
being transparent I grew up in a
dysfunctional family where there wasn't
a whole lot of encouragement shared and
maybe you come from a family or even a
culture that does not value
encouragement so I've had to learn
encouragement and it's just like any
other skill it's something that you can
learn to let me help you so imagine you
have a co-worker named Mary you can go
up to Mary and say Mary I am so thankful
for the work that you do for our team
the database work that you do is so
valuable and not only that but you're
always smiling and cheerful you just
brighten everyone's day thank you for
being awesome Paul thank you for always
being willing to help I know I can
always count on you when I come to you
with a problem you seem to have just
great insight and able to help me find a
solution thank you you are awesome
mark thank you for always wearing
deodorant
and coming to work fully clothed keep up
the good work buddy
see it's not that hard you can find
things to encourage other people about
and it will make their day and inspire
them to do more and better things
some of you know Joe Joe Armstrong he's
been a speaker here at in DC Oslo
several times we lost an incredible
champion of the developer community this
year and I want to honor Joe I hope you
if you've been here to NDC Oslo before I
hope you got an opportunity to hear one
of his talks or to get to meet him I got
to meet him I wish I wish I'd gotten to
know him better but here's this was a
man who did amazing things in the
developer community he not only helped
create you know Erlang language but just
the contributions that he made you know
have inspired countless people and the
applications you know is his influence
is just incalculable if there's someone
who has impacted you in some way either
recently or in the past let them know
about it don't wait until it's it's too
late now
I have one more story that I want to
share with you I want to take you back
to 1982 and in the u.s. we have a
holiday called Thanksgiving and in our
family our tradition was that we all got
together at my aunt and uncle's house we
would me and my brothers and sister
would pile in the car with my mom and we
drive two hours away and we'd have
dinner it's like a big family reunion
and this particular fateful Thanksgiving
in 1982 I discovered in my cousin's
house one of these now I don't know if I
spent the entire day sitting down at
this trs-80 but I do know it made an
impression on my uncle and sometime
after Thanksgiving my mom got a phone
call
and we got in the car and we drove two
hours to my aunt and uncle's house and
they're waiting for me was a big
cardboard box and inside was trs-80 a
cassette drive a floppy drive a dot
matrix printer a whole bunch of cables
and this book this one kind and very
generous act launched me on a journey of
computers and the love for technology
and I continue to be inspired by my aunt
and uncle's example of investing not
only in their family but in countless
others and I I cannot thank them enough
for the impact that they made on me my I
wouldn't be here today if it weren't for
them
you have amazing potential to impact
your family and your relatives and your
community you never know if some act of
kindness a word of encouragement maybe a
small investment of your time could be
that catalyst that inspires someone else
on their lifelong journey of exploration
and their livelihood when you walk out
of these doors today you have a choice
you can you can continue learning and
growing you have the choice to share
your awesomeness with others and your
adventure your story your hero story is
only just beginning so this is my
challenge to you regardless of your age
the amount of experience your job title
your role you have amazing potential to
impact your workplace your family your
community in powerful significant ways I
encourage you to maximize your talents
go be courageous go do those hard things
go inspire others go and be awesome
thank you
[Applause]